thank you thank you for inviting me yeah
i don't need this
it's really an honor and pleasure to
speak in honor of david blackwell
so i think daniel like that like the
same picture
so
when i was a graduate student in the
late 80s i remember reading
my interview by david blackford probably
around 1986.
it's not exactly the same code but in
spirit was the same about simplicity and
that stuck in my mind both about
understanding david said that i'm not
interested in doing research
and never have been i'm interesting
understanding which is quite a different
thing i open to understand something you
have to work out yourself because no one
else has done it
and there's another code that's what i
remembered from daily cal
always look for the simplest solution
so to me they have been the nos star for
my research understanding and simplicity
so let's look at
one quote from former chancellor al
balker about david's teaching
he said he's ideal faculty member first
and foremost he's an excellent classroom
performer
i will show you a little clip to show
you uh what actually david does in class
i'm really regretting that when i was
graduating he was still teaching the
beijing statistic class that was at 8 00
a.m
neymar had a night i could make it for
but i didn't make it it's really regret
um his classes have both been rigorous
and popular and he was also released at
the supervised menu
he was popular
well you guys the best students
i think i think if you as good as david
you can have a class anytime
i want to just see this book i think
it's really beijing's the tsa he called
basic statistics
and that's the whole preface
just half a page
so i think i'll let you read it like
david speak for himself
it's just so all right that you know
kids have forgotten high school algebra
and say exactly what he would do
in a very short concise and elegant way
and in the end he said beijing he didn't
put in the title there was later book by
barry i think did that
so that's kind of david's style in his
own world and now we have a building in
honor of david
and that's his family
two generations
and if you want
google it it's not far
and
this
portrait of david actually was donated
by a former student uh
richard davis
so he was extremely popular as
a undergraduate
professor and here's some quotes from
his first phd student
he said to david blackwell
who
with his characteristically concise
sentence tell me among other things how
to write a mathematical paper how to
locate mathematics how to welcome
responsibility and how to face my small
mature years that's what i need
this paper is affectionately dedicated
i wish david is around to tell me how to
live my
mature years
maybe future would tell me
and another student
who
i think david had more than 50 like 65.
so david give a talk at stanford
berkeley culcum which is still going and
he described certain i think it's about
something called programmable sets
and he which is richard was amazed by
how clear easy was trying to tell
everyone about it
so quickly that lecture was a very clear
representation some not so easy at all
and david had the capacity to organize
argument far far better than i the idea
is simple as it described
and
other people who didn't work with him
there's this wonderful volume called a
tribute to david blackwell
so david blacker was a teacher without
parallel i was particularly impressed by
how he could make truly deep concept
transparent simplicity is not because
it's actually simple it's because you
understand so well that becomes simple
it's a lot of work even to the beginner
indeed that that was such that
understanding sometimes blossom
mysteriously
and gradually i record doing over class
notes after class and only then begin to
understand how deep and subtle some of
the concepts he had presented were
i just enjoy remind myself how wonderful
david was oh this is going the wrong way
and
there's also a very good
interview by
maurice the crew
of a conversation with david ball and in
the interview mars asked him what's your
favorite paper
so let's hear david my first episode
called on an equation
word
grew after the original conversation
with abe gershog was really a mentor for
many many years for david this is a
paper i'm still very proud of it give me
prep please and feelings
so let's all remember that one
old mature years which papers give us
warm feelings and this is really good to
know whether you remember
you over produce papers then i don't
think
that's what david would suggest we do
he said what the main idea for one thing
was proof of word theorem under i think
weaker condition had been
true before under sort of natural
conditions and he said the proof is neat
and he went to the blackboard and here's
from the interview i just
cut and paste it i didn't see this
proof before i learned it some other way
you just replicate the stopping time
many many times have this s1 sk
and then you just write it out this is
trivial and use lot our larger numbers
that's it
i definitely didn't learn this in class
so this is just neat i completely great
just so intuitive and so simple
and we don't need all these fancy things
that we use to learn to prove it
so internal intellectual um
overlap david and i did overlap which i
learned more from david on the topic of
information there this is just very nice
website it's all david's papers
and in particular you see two papers
with
two colleagues oh i think leo bryant was
a student and a colleague automation
and
there was this interview uh leo breiman
about the history of how why
brian proved this theorem actually the
idea came from david
the obama said that we use decision
seminars he would send me this little
note saying can you prove this in this
and this
and one that knows he's sensitive like
can you prove this thing converge almost
surely to the following i'm sure
probably the entropy organic theorem and
i thought about it for the next couple
of days and now i said yes i can do that
i can see how to do that
so that became the shannon bryman
macmillan theorem which is for entropy
convergence for ergodic processes and
david's for black what brian was
incredibly inspirational person to work
with to see his mind work was the of
course leo himself was really a giant
himself but you can see all these giant
minds really uh interacted
and for me i didn't really get to know
david as a graduate admired him
tremendously but didn't really interact
with him and i came back as uh assistant
professor in the early 90s and then i
started interacting with david moore and
this is a photo from an attribute to
blackwell and even see myself i didn't
know this there was such a photo
and david blinder who was another
giant from statistics
said that being david's colleague has
been a privilege and i fully heard it
heartedly agree with david his honors
accomplishment visit here about a few of
many in the arbitration
and you can see many colleagues eric
layman ching chi chang and kerry kaufman
and julie schaefer so this was one the
the department used to have a birthday
party for everybody in the same month
maybe you should revive that i think
there was a
some same photo with peter and eric and
david
so my interactions with uh dave black
after came back was a lot of bumping
into him in the morning
um around eight if i come in early
going the side of evans hall and would
go to the third floor
and check out the mails and that's where
he will go or we encounter him in the
elevator so a lot of elevator and
hallway talks
and
christmas party he will always bring
this eggnog very strong liquor in it and
so every christmas party i don't think i
tried much i probably tried it once
and during my difficult times i could
always turn to david for support he was
always just so warm a matter of fact
and a tremendous
and i was able to get david to drive me
to a conference and uc center group so
we had long rise
uh
conference on online prediction of
individual sequences by the counselor
and warmers i actually have to reach out
to you up front
to help remind me
exactly what's the topic i remember more
the conversations than the topic of the
conference
so in one of the rights i think i was
going to some difficult times and i said
what david
gone through must be just
like different magnitude so i asked him
i said david how do you deal with it
and that's what he said he said the
people who help you and people who don't
that's fair
so he was very very calm and never
really made me feel like i'm sure all
the tremendous difficulties he just
didn't show
and other things i took away
from david in my conversation with him
which i very much agree with the first
one we shall hire top young people into
tenure track
and tenure them
unless something goes really wrong
they'll really remove all the pressures
of publishing over production papers
these days
and
[Music]
the other one is like because i was
teaching information theory class
and wanted david to speak to my class or
to my group i forgot which it was
and he refused
he would say that it's your time
and not my time he was so clear and i
remind myself i took some of my younger
colleagues that
just tell me to get off right if i get
to a stage that you think i should go
but i don't want to go
so it's don't over stay your time so
that was very very wise
david was davis was maybe a little older
but i'm just
wanting to take the wisdom from david
and
to um provide myself doing something
actually my relation i wouldn't want to
do
when david passed away
i was actually department chair
and
i had really the privilege to work with
his kids and got to know some of them
and to prepare for this memory we did in
i house
and in the process preparing for that i
really learned more about david there
was this wonderful oral history with
four sessions by this person from the
bankrupt library
nadine woman and
it's on the internet i really encourage
you to read it one thing i was surprised
when i read this oral history after
david passed away who said david was a
genius
and why
we don't see this word used on david as
much as
should have been
so i was so surprised to learn that he
learned
reading by going to his uncle's grocery
store
just look at those goods potato and the
bag
how many of us could figure that out
i was so impressed that
so when they start we know
that
you can learn just by going to a grocery
store
and in the same interview
he also talked about the motivation of
games near work i think this the theme
of the semester
which is again gershock played a role
because he was in washington during the
war
and working with a unit called operation
research office in washington and he was
working on game theory and optimization
theory
and
it was very much war
efforts related
and david
i think i'm sure you guys can tell me
that actually i'm useful in practice too
but david saw that he was just doing it
for the sake of beautiful mathematics
let me share
more um
words from his students
in this collection called after he
possibly a tribute to david blackwell so
george russes i also know who was a
student here and professor at uc davis
and he i think characterized david
as a person in the most concise and
simplistic way
professor blackwell's personality was
overwhelming strong and yet gentle and
enchanting relating kindness around him
i think that's the people who know david
would agree
and herbert lowe i think was a student
him
said something also give you a little
detail about how david was alike david
is true he always wear similar jacket
like whitish
and
joe oat
car and
he was not an interest in teaching
graduate courses he was interested in
teaching undergraduate conscious that's
where his impact was
and i missed my chance i couldn't get up
at 8.
and
more
comments from this attribute to david
blackbull
and
professor maiden peru said that
a sense of pride that david was a rare
individual who possessed warmth
integrity humility intellectual passion
a commitment to students faculty
colleagues and friends alike he had
another paragraph about how great friend
david was he had the courage to take a
stand on important issues that's i think
hugely important in today's world
the qualities that the creative gifted
scholar imbued with high moral sense is
supposed to possess
i think we should put that on our
faculty evaluation
and we're fortunate we had such a person
as our colleague
i returned to the theme of
simplicity a colleague and judy schaefer
said he liked elegance and simplicity
issues had to be cleared in the very
simplicity of situations so he didn't
like empirical basis because it kind of
mixed up a very clear coherent
framework
i remember david telling me that
real patients as people which are very
much agreed with it's really the the
analytical progress i some probably
different with david
empirical based didn't meet his test he
felt a bayesian pride was necessary his
ability to clarify issues in simple
elegant ways was presumably what made
him such an outstanding lecturing
teacher so the understanding and the
effort and also simplicity all connected
so back
i will call this actually a given name
blackwell's way
understanding and simplicity and my
favorite photo david
of course simplicity has been
a philosophy science for decades or not
centuries
and my connection simplicity actually i
did a thesis on mdl which is the
quantification of simplicity using
combination theory
and i would think that i think i start
working information in 1987 with
terrorist speed and i remember reading
about simplicity with davies common
probably 1986 so there was some
connection which i couldn't completely
remember
i still pursue
simplicity to this day
and oops
that's right
so it's in terms of algorithms
so we have i'm going to make decisions
on whom to get ct scan
whom to give loans to
whom to give job interviews to whom to
grant payroll to
and both understanding and simplicity
very much in need in these situations
for inter-promotional learning
and decision tree is actually quite
simple i'm not sure it's always gives us
understanding that's what you have to
put in the context to do but
at least about all the machine learning
algorithms decision trees are simple
integrable and the hoping will bring
understanding as well can be visualized
implemented a mirror ways people think
and so you can look at arrows and biases
more accessibly
and maybe physical human in the loop
flow
and instills trust and distress
on the model we
develop
so we have been working very closely
with people in um
ucsf i have my former student now msr
shenzhen singh and aaron complex i mean
chandan made this slide
i don't have the ability to do that
and we really try to help er doctors to
decide when to send the injured child
say abdominal injury to a ct or not
on one hand if you sent to ct can be
over radiation and you also don't want
to miss internal bleeding so this is the
tree that we we're dealing with
and decision trees are building blocks
random forests and greeting
boosting right this is something that
have very good performance
but
if you look at decision trees
you have a gap decision don't work as
well as random forest or
actually boosting
and can we bridge the gap
and keep the simplicity
so
for the next part
i'll tell you um
a lower bound result
to show that when you have additive
structures decision fields cannot reach
optimal rate and using actual
information theory so that's kind of
cool connect with david's work not
exactly but at least information theory
and the second part can we have to build
in some additive structure to have
additive trees and to bridge both versus
simplicity and also to make able to um
capture the additive structure so this
is the team of people i work with
and um
shutout now national university
singapore keiyan now working for google
messaging china introduced and abby's
current student in statistics
so if you look at decision tree theory
there's a tree
and there are kind of three branches one
is future importance can you guess
something important of a gene
or a factor out so it's a whole line of
work on that
oh point y convergence right can you
look at the point as a non-parametric
estimation and get some consistency in
rates for cart and random force all
point white asymptotic number so they're
kind of three branches
none of them address the question
or give direct understanding why
decision tree don't work so well in
practice
so what we try to do is to really bring
that inside
that adjective structures actually not
the best fit for decision tree so here's
a simulated model without even noise you
have additive
boolean functions
and then you do a decision tree you will
end up doing
try to match because the additivity have
to do many splits on x3 to accommodate
the fact that this additivity
and you look at the performance
you see a performance drop right you can
simulate model with additive structures
you just see that things don't work as
well
as you show in the boolean example
but we do want to do attitude models
right i hope you all agree and here's a
reason actually many real world data
sets actually have additive structure
and we have success with least squares
right and left
and there's a lot of non-promotional
relations of these squares from the 80s
and
we
want to understand why decisions didn't
work
so here's a simple
model
you have data on
the cube because random forests and
trees it's really monotonic uh trend
like in variance so this is not too
restricted
assumption just for mass to go more
simply
and we assume that you have additive
model
and the it model has to be a little
smooth
and you look at all possible trees so
this is a low boundary sound it's not
upper bound result and then you can show
that
you have this lower bound take any tree
you want oracle or not you have this
rate
and actually happens that early work
from my student i think we're right we
have the optimal rate for this class but
you have each individual component to
have some smoothness
and you match unless s is one basically
one component it's already additive
these two rates don't match
so this really explained that
there's something missing if you do
trees and you have additive structure so
the proof i won't have time to go to is
a bias variance decomposition you see a
little bit that in the earlier talk
actually
and you
you map the trees as logic codes and you
do re-dissociation theory information
theory together to get the lower bound
so back to this example
where you have
a problem right you you always split
down x3 to accommodate for the additive
structure
so what we do
grow multiple trees bring additivity
into the game
or disentangle
the different effect through additivity
and so that we can adapt to higher order
interactions
so i also been working on decisions a
lot with genomics problems that's also a
very good fit is random forest but this
is more for interval uh like
clinical use so we want to control the
complexity we don't want to have too
many splits or we aim for simplicity
and we actually can see compare with
decision trees we can improve prediction
performance and we therefore
fewer false discourages so on the other
line research my group does we really
want to do recommendations for knockdown
experiments so we don't like false
discoveries we want high yields
and with all of that we introduce the
fast integral greedy tree sums fix
genius my students
and
we modify high level the card split to
grow a flexible number of trees
simultaneously
and control the total number of splits
among the addition and we do back
fitting
because when you have additive
structures you use the residues to when
you feed new components
so this is the card algorithm if you're
not familiar what you do you have say
three predictors
and you look for go through one by one
and see if i do a split and feed the
constant after you do the split which
one gives you the big reduction of
this squares
arrow
and then you just split and you do two
cards again
they don't get connection anymore and
you look and that's what you end up with
even you have a simple
boolean additive model you end up with
more than you need
so how about fix fix is very much just
building on cart the first one just like
cart
and then for the second one you have the
choice
of
splitting with the first one or add a
note
and then you consider all three of them
and you look at use the reflected
the residuals for each component you
compare the job and then you choose one
so it's coordinated across all splits
and then you might not you might want to
keep splitting without doing an additive
component and you just go so it's very
simple it's very easy to explain and
then we get
runtime we do
take more computation time but it's only
r times r is the numbers place you want
to do which is under your controls so
it's like a multiplicative compared with
the uh card runtime
and the results we improve prediction
performance and keep simplicity as much
as we can
and with this entangled additive
components yes
why like making this adjective is a good
idea remember we showed that if you the
data have additive structure
the trees
has mismatched optimal like us has some
optimal rate
so it shows that trees is not to
accommodate additive structure in your
data
and you believe that in practice there
are a lot of cases that you have added
to the structure yeah
that's what i try to make right study
square works all of that so i'll show
you that this is a bunch of public data
sets
and you will see that
with both regression and also um
classification
then this is the data i only show you
classification assuming that you
basically have a lift about ten percent
across different data sets if you look
at this recidivism it's by pro that
actually
random forest
doesn't work this is really have
discrete structure but even look at all
the different discrete
this is all different like discrete
structure card or decision trees and we
have a whole lift of performance
and here you can see that when i have
too many we lose it but when you have
one really really simple explanations
you see a little performance
so this is shows that i have another
panel i want to show you just in the
interest of time for regression similar
performance
and let's dig into
something which we get some
understanding so this is a particular
data diabetes classification data set
and if you do cart
you have auc which is the area under the
curve
about eighty-one percent
and you get
eight
if i continue right notes right that's
just a split for making this prediction
if you use
fix
this is actually two splits of two we're
not doing three splits but we write it
into one
and you only end up with five and you
get tiny this is not major but you don't
lose
so this shows that you can really
simplify things for understanding too
this probably has some additive
structure for this data the signatures
have to come in there by making more and
more split and here you have simple
things and then for the different
adjective trees we have a lot of people
won't have to get to you can also
imagine that each tree is characterizing
a different heterogeneous population of
disease mechanisms
that they don't fit together
and then you have scores adding up so
each tree gives you a score and you add
up the scores for each trait
okay so that's what they're saying that
you can have predictive risk of white
sound plus
plasma glucose and the other is based on
bmi the other one h you just add them up
and then that's you get a predictory
score
just to understand the difference from
something like staying with me that
you're not
saying or you're not taking a convex
combination of the truth they're just
literally happy
yeah the item is different we do end up
it's different and the way we use the
previous information
so we use it through
uh the residuals right and
boosting does too but then you do
rewriting
and x boosts we actually have a
follow-up paper we we compare is that we
sometimes do better than x boost
sometimes
uh we need to use our nodes to reach the
performance but there for some data we
can keep the simplicity but also imagine
so
we do have uh i don't have time yet
thanks for the question
so back
to um
the
i would say uh ubiquitous presence of
algorithm out in our
life especially for high stakes decision
making
i would call i would say black hole's
way emphasizing understanding
and simplicity both of which have big
roles to play in making algorithm safe
and to return to what i started with
about
blackwell
being a master teacher
i like to quote a historian
statistical history uh historian steve
skiller stickler from university of
chicago who was a student at berkeley i
think in the 70s or 60s i mean
i just like to rate
what uh
steve said
he's a very very good writer
um
a tribute to david blackwell which is
what
it's a collection of notices from
american
mathematical society i have that in the
most like yeah so it's after david
passed away um george russell's edited
this um i think you had a piece i did
yeah
everybody was asked to write a
one-to-one like half a page
and from former student advised by him
to students at berkeley and colleagues
about 20 i think
attributes
struck me was that
his mastery came from the way he was
thinking through the material with us at
our speed
and making his thoughts our thoughts
i think this is if any secret to this
and
it was a magic
and a lasting magic
things the knowledge
in party remained with us so just give
you a sense into the magic i found this
video clip
and find how to press it
it was a video made when david
was
awarded the national medal signs after
he passed away i think pedro was one of
the nominators
that made that happen
that's david's voice
blackwell joined and soon after headed
the university of california berkeley's
newly created statistics department
over the years blackwell continued to
expand mathematics by introducing game
theory decision theory and information
theory into the field
that we
equal to a knew
david blackwell
the first african-american elected to
the national academy of sciences
dedicated to assisting disadvantaged
students in the u.s and
first the africa i would give to
young people generally is
try everything
and keep working until you find
something that you like
[Music]
i hope you find time to watch the whole
video
every day
[Music]
so the references are here thank you
well do i want to take a couple
questions before we break for lunch
okay so let's let's wrap up here and uh
we'll meet back at two o'clock back on
schedule uh for the afternoon uh and so
uh see everybody then thank you thank
you